you want to talk about omicron
oh yeah
son more uh okay
so we got a new variant coming from
south africa yeah brand new release just
dropped and i feel bad
for south africa because it's called the
south african variant it's the omicron
variant but like it's known as the south
african one and basically biden was like
yo we gotta shut down travel from south
africa they're being mad races yeah this
is why all those white africans brothers
like superstars
but what is real [ __ ] up about it is
that south africa is like yo yo yo
we just we just found it you know like
it ain't even ours like we was just the
first ones it's like whoever smelled the
delty yeah like that's them that's the
perfect example smell the delta like the
[ __ ] could come from zimbabwe yeah but
since they don't have like the
sophisticated viral technology over
there obviously because of aids in south
africa they know about the virus [ __ ]
like crazy there's like a lot of like
money that's getting put into this
so
they were just the one to pick it up and
now everybody's blaming them and low-key
i'm like if i'm another country i didn't
see nothing
yeah like this is the worst way to react
to it i understand obviously you want to
make sure that you know a new virus
doesn't get into your country shut [ __ ]
down you always got to deal with the
what is the people the supply chain
issues blah blah blah right everybody
wants to make sure the supply chain is
fine but you were
what's called disincentivizing
distance yeah you're punishing the
people for doing the right thing yes
you're disincentivizing these people
that are doing the right thing yeah
because they know of any new variant
pops up anywhere now that's on you yeah
but it could have been a [ __ ]
from china that went to south africa we
developed this whole system to not do
that we had this whole [ __ ]
delta omicron whatever the [ __ ] epsilon
yeah the whole naming system and then we
just said [ __ ] it it's a south african
strain it's a south african strain
haven't they been through enough and but
the funniest thing
the funniest thing about the the south
african [ __ ] is that they skipped over
they skipped two they skipped over two
letters yeah because they're doing it
off of the greek alphabet yeah so what
are the two letters that they skipped
new new and kai and kai now new
that's fire news frame it's the new
string they want to skip it because they
thought i'd make confusion with people
being like yo the news strain and people
like what
it is the new strain
there's gonna be a new strain later and
they're gonna be like oh yeah the new
strength the new one they're like no no
the old one that's called new and you're
like why did they skip that one who's on
first [ __ ] that's what they're
afraid i understand that a little bit
yeah with the world health organization
yeah right
what is the letter after nu kai now kai
how do you spell that oh it's not kai it
is kai no you were also a fraternity and
had to know this it's not zai it's i
know it's kai we were in a fraternity
called kaisai
and it was spelled chf
yeah that's a good point yeah no that's
chai side
mind blowing that's cha it's zai are you
sure
yeah fraternity dudes are the smartest
people
i thought i'll be honest you said kai
yesterday and i was like i guess this
guy is wrong don't put that on me you
did you said kai yesterday don't do this
again you didn't say kai you said kai on
the floor
the son of bert massey
um okay so zy yeah is spelled x-i yeah
the president or prime minister or
whatever [ __ ] fake position the
dictator of china has is jiji ping yeah
spelled x-i
now they skip over this letter because
they don't want it to be stigmatized
yeah they don't they don't want to
agitate yeah
that was their literal answer they're
like we don't want to we don't want to
we're fine with it being the south
african yeah you're stigmatized south
africa instead of ceo of delta i'm like
what the [ __ ] are we doing bro yeah
corona
we've been stigmatized this whole time
we basically put corona through the
[ __ ] uh what is it called bankruptcy
bankruptcy yeah corona was paying us to
promote it yeah remember when they gave
us cases of corona they're like please
just put it on corona's got talent we'll
do anything to get out of this thing
they literally almost went bankrupt
because we call it the coronavirus yeah
okay delta same [ __ ] thing yeah we
still wrote delta yeah but still
it's absolute [ __ ] and the second
that they could agitate
chyna daddy daddy immediately bends the
[ __ ] knee you know for a fact if
trump called the strain or the tr if
trump's last name was some [ __ ] uh
letter of the greek alphabet they would
have named that [ __ ] after him and he
would have owned it too probably 100 can
i say another unfair thing that trump
did when trump had a travel ban
everybody lost their [ __ ] minds you
can't this is this is not enough to
institute a travel ban for a whole
country all right fine this is a virus
however what we are seeing is the
symptoms are very mild
very mild is what the south african uh
doctor said and we're we're banning the
whole country from traveling over very
mild covered yeah i don't give a [ __ ] so
it seems like there's a conspiracy here
and i want to get to mark about this
because we can get into the conspiracy
corner and figure out exactly why we're
making such a big deal about this but
what i think real quick before we go
there what i think is very interesting
is and maybe this is part of conspiracy
and i tweeted about this the other day
and got in whatever interesting
reactions but
i i think what we're seeing is a very
brilliant tactical play by china
america
has always used freedom internationally
as a tool
to weaken the control
of tyrannical governments over their
people right we have freedom here we're
like yo you guys deserve free wait
you're not free but you're humans you
should be free go watch this movie that
shows how awesome freedom is go watch
these music videos and show how awesome
for you you guys should be able to be
free too you should be able to free wear
whatever you want do whatever you want
live however you want with your life you
deserve freedom right it's a great tool
and it's a really great tool because
anybody who sees freedom goes i would
like some of that
nobody ever goes i want more rules yeah
no one sees a movie about north korea
and they're like that seems fun right i
would like rules 100
no one sees a [ __ ] world war two
movie and the gestapo showing up to your
house you're like hitler someone
checking on me yeah never once right
freedom is so [ __ ] tantalizing so if
our most powerful tool
in the culture war is freedom they have
to find a way to handicap the freedom
what if
what if hypothetically they leaned into
and promoted the extremes of that
freedom
so that we would have to limit our own
what do you mean you are free
for example to be 75 different [ __ ]
genders yeah you're free to identify as
um
a shoe
you're basically saying like a psyop to
use freedom against people and now
you're going to force the american
government to be like well you're not
that free yeah
there's a limit to the freedom right you
don't go too far with this [ __ ]
freedom what if they continue to lean in
to the extremes of whatever the [ __ ]
that we want to do here and we should be
able to do it because we're free right
to create that sort of
that i don't want to call it like um
uh
i don't want to say i don't want to say
there's like descent but this beef to
continue to to to prop up this beef from
different size on both the extremes on
what you should be able to so you're
saying they're propping up the the
arguments if i was them i would yeah who
benefits the most from it us no yeah
we're fighting amongst ourselves we
can't fight anybody else yeah i would
lean into anything i would lean into
anything that causes some sort of uh
discord is that the word i'm looking for
dissonance
i think discord is doored whatever i
would lean into anything i possibly
could and
essentially what you're doing if you're
leaning into the woke side which i'm
sure they would and you lean into the
opposite of work whatever it is but if
you're leaning into the woke side right
like think about that if i'm if i'm
china
right and i'm going to use wokeness as a
tool against america
that's brilliant
hey
i'm going to protect any criticism of
china by calling it racist
hey we call this the china virus
that's racist yeah you could be
stigmatized people are going to get beat
up in the streets because of this and
you do anything that you possibly can to
eliminate any criticism of china the
country yeah
by leaning into those people in america
that are
that are pushing this progressive agenda
of hey we cannot do anything racist
words or violence if you are critical of
china in any way that could reflect on
chinese people that are here in america
or asians are here in america so let's
stop that criticism entirely if there's
a uk strain by all means criticize the
uk if there's a the the the south
african strain by all means if there's
an indian strain by all means criticize
that but any sort of chinese criticism
of the government could reflect poorly
on chinese people therefore we shouldn't
do it yeah
yeah i would think even another way to
do it is if we are
if we're playing conspiracy theorists if
we're like addicted to freedom we love
freedom what if there's a virus that
gets spread that the government is
forced to limit everyone's freedom that
would cause a lot of unrest if the
mandates are you have to wear masks all
the time you have to get vaccinated you
have to do this you have to do that it's
so ingrained in our dna to be free that
a lot of people are going to be like no
[ __ ] that and then they have a problem
you have used the freedom against
america because they had a limit to
freedom so now there's uh dissonance i
guess would be the better word
dissonance with within the government
like i [ __ ] these guys dude they're
they're limiting my freedom
they're my enemy now
because i can i can definitely see how i
always thought it was like politicians
who were beholden to daddy china were
like hey leaning into how dare trump
call it the china virus and everything
else who gives a [ __ ] i gotta make sure
china's protected because we need them
so that's what i thought it was and then
that just kind of filtered in
and i didn't see china leaning into it
but they could i just don't i would
anytime you're critical of china i mean
loki this is uh this is done with uh
jews in israel it's like any time
there's a criticism of israel
it often gets turned into anti-semitism
right now are there people who are
critical critical of israel that are
anti-semitic yeah absolutely you might
even make you might even make the case
that it's 95
maybe 99 you can make that case but
there is also a percentage of people
like the israelis that are critical of
their own government they could have
nothing to do with israel-palestine it
could literally just be like yo the
[ __ ] taxes in israel are crazy high
like when i was there that's what they
were saying the taxes are crazy hot
right are they anti-semitic
of course not no but when it's tied in
now all of a sudden you have to be
really careful about what you criticize
about the country yeah because you could
become hateful as well through it i
think if we're criticizing china and the
way they handle kovit i think that's
completely reasonable i don't think
there's anything if you can't see the
difference between the chinese
government and chinese people you're
[ __ ] [ __ ] i can't you're an idiot
you're an idiot
it's the complete as a matter of fact
the chinese government does more [ __ ] to
chinese people than any [ __ ] black
guy on the subway yeah i mean you want
to talk about harm chinese government
harming mad chinese people [ __ ] the
chinese government because i love
chinese people
that's interesting okay mark give us the
conspiracy theory about the omicron
variant so there's a few different ones
that have been kind of percolating
basically people are looking at it like
oh they're just going to kick up any new
strain to try to enact more government
control so like the new york mayor
basically said we're going to do
emergency orders because it's coming
so that basically gives the government
locally and different countries
more rule less restrictions they don't
have to go through the same you know
judicial and democratic process because
it's an emergency and they're basically
using this like the old saying don't let
any good crisis go to waste they're
using this thing blowing it up bigger
than it actually is to then get more
control the other thing that people are
saying is it's possible that once in
america at least once the boosters are
now available for everyone
basically stoking enough fear about the
new variant
boosters
people are going to go get more boosters
make more money for the pharmaceutical
companies that are then doing kickbacks
with the media with the politicians and
i believe in that that i believe
i believe in that because literally
someone close to dove got coveted even
though they were vaxxed okay their hubby
also got coveted even though they were
vexed bad coven no okay
but they got it again yeah so
i jumped to the conclusion that this was
the new one this is the omicron yeah i
immediately told my parents i was like
yo y'all should get the booster right
because i don't want my [ __ ] parents
to die because there's this new kobe
that came around i didn't research it i
didn't look at what they the health
minister said in south africa basically
said it's mild symptoms yeah right um
which is the suggestion for most viruses
like we've talked about before like as
it mutates it becomes more
uh transmittable but less virulent so it
doesn't kill all the hosts right so
basically and and i think it was you
maybe when we were discussing this a
little bit yesterday was it you were
saying like this is the perfect
i think i was saying it oh yeah
said this yesterday he was brilliant he
was like yo this is the perfect thing we
go what he goes if there's a covid that
everybody gets but it doesn't kill you
like on some chicken pox [ __ ] it's like
we're done yeah everybody gets it
everybody builds up their antibodies
whether you're a vax or not doesn't
matter because you're gonna have natural
immunity after having it yeah this is
the perfect type of covenant yeah are we
stopping south africa from bringing it
over run it up yeah dude i do not care
honestly if you haven't gotten covered
by now you're probably a [ __ ] loser
you got no friends [ __ ] you also if you
get it it's like saying there's a new
strain of runny nose i don't care if it
don't kill me i don't care it's the flu
i ain't give a [ __ ] about bird flu i
ain't think about pig flu i'm gonna [ __ ]
about bat flu i'm good and what made me
suspicious with the booster [ __ ] was
they're like get get your booster now
yeah and then i'm seeing new stories
that uh moderna and pfizer will have
booster uh boosters that are like
prepared for the omicron environment
within three months varying within three
months so why would i get the booster
now if in three months they're gonna be
ready for the variant it's just like yo
no you know i realize man and this is
where like i wonder like what how much
blame you can give media
but
when you start positioning and this is
also politician but when you start
positioning
this is the overreaction of politicians
to
new variants and the virus in general
when you start positioning
the covet deaths as the responsibility
of trump
the next person in office or the
governors of each state
are going to feel accountable for those
deaths so if it's not the virus killed a
hundred thousand if trump killed a
hundred thousand by the way he handled
the virus now if you're buying you're
like oh you're not gonna put these
bodies on me yeah shut down south africa
yeah you know what i'm saying if you're
the governor of california governor of
new york you're like oh what i got the
subway everybody's in the subway
everybody's about to go to hang out with
their family for christmas you're not
going to put these bodies on me when you
start reporting the deaths as the
responsibility of the politician in
charge this is the natural reaction and
even blame them shits on the [ __ ]
virus even beyond the virus which is
definitely true but trump in general is
so radioactive any similarity you have
to trump you can't do that yeah you
can't be anything like trump in any way
so that's even more so like all right
let's shut everything down but i don't
care yeah i do believe in the vaccine
but you don't got to get [ __ ] booster
for omicron [ __ ] that yeah [ __ ] that
that's that point on that no it was uh
that's what the experts are saying that
right now delta is 90 of the world and
it's
deadly as other ones were so if this one
becomes mild so i'm not a doctor
recommending anyone get covered but
virologists are saying they're
cautiously optimistic that if the
omicron variant is less pathogenic but
more transmissible allowing omicron to
replace delta this would be positive
optimistic cautiously is a word for
[ __ ] i'm optimistic if you haven't
gotten covered yet you're a [ __ ]
loser go get that omicron you ain't got
no [ __ ] friends
unless you got autoimmune or some [ __ ]
you got a valid reason that you got to
be careful be careful but if you're just
some [ __ ] cuck in a house go get
covered what if you want to just get the
booster
then you a [ __ ]
why why why no you're going to tell your
parents to get the boosters yeah i don't
i want to get the booster yet at least
let them i got my dad
already if it's been eight months i
don't think you need a booster you got a
booster oh my dad got it oh yeah yeah i
would let my parents get a boost i don't
think you need one in like eight months
wait a year at least like we're just
gonna do eight months and then they're
gonna have this [ __ ] medicine
eventually that is
like uh the antiviral pill that yeah
merck has but the crazy thing is that
they just still won't tell us what our
natural immunity uh that we developed is
worth because they sell more vaccines
this way that's just a they're hustling
once that data comes out that we were
good the whole time yeah um but if
people want to get the booster i'm like
yeah do whatever you want yeah do it
you're just a [ __ ]
you're like the guy wearing a mask to
order a salad for three minutes if a guy
wants to wear a mask i'm like yeah go
away yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah do it with your cook okay
maybe that's what i'm saying
i don't think that you're a cook at a
certain age all right i think if you're
our age getting the booster you're a
[ __ ] also i don't know someone's
disability yeah no that's i was in a
zone that's fine
i don't know someone's disability
someone's sick i'm talking about i'm not
talking about people who are [ __ ]
crippled yeah pre-existing autumn i mean
you got any of that [ __ ] get it
normal healthy people under 40 that are
getting a booster yeah under 40. like
that getting a booster come on bro like
what are you doing like that's some
[ __ ] losers you feel the same way
about the flu shot i never got a flu
shot in my life
but if someone under 40 gets a flu shot
are you a loser
get the flu all right
just get the flu you ever had the flu
say what you ever had the flu
dude that [ __ ] is brutal is it though
yes i can't wait till you say the flu is
brutal while we're having a pandemic
blue hey real talk this is brutal supply
issues
it's so brutal we talk about jordan we
go man jordan's a goat for playing
through the flu if is it brutal or
really had the not
come on because he really had the flu he
would have been able to make it he would
have been able to play that game he
really had the flu exactly
regular flu probably worse than regular
covert it kova just kills way more
people when it gets bad it gets worse
but i think
the reason it's an issue is is the
duration
if it was a day or two you'd be fine
but this [ __ ] is 10 days like i was how
long were y'all out for covet yeah i got
i got the least bad out of everybody i
gave it to which is kind of i felt bad
about that
when you had co when i had coconut it
sort of felt like that but it was just
forever i was never [ __ ] you tired for
like five years
i got emotional in that pool house after
day six like you ever pull a muscle and
you're just like still like four days
later you want to just go work out
you're like still my hamstring is still
[ __ ] up i can't do [ __ ] that's covered
every time i hurt my body that's it's
i'm shocked how long it's
two weeks like this
what's going on here
you